the first I guess you could say modern
conception of an acid in base comes from
this gentleman right over here Svante
Arrhenius and he was actually the third
recipient of the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry in 1903 and his definition of
acids under under his definition of
acids and bases an acid is something
that increases the concentration
increases increases the concentration
concentration of hydrogen protons we
could say protons when when put in an
aqueous solution when in aqueous aqueous
solution that's just a water solution
and then you could imagine what a base
would be you could think well maybe it
basically something that decreases the
protons and that's one way to think
about it or you could say or you could
say it decreases actually let me write
this it increases it increases it
increases the hydroxide concentration it
increases the hydroxide concentration
concentration when put in aqueous
solution when in aqueous aqueous
solution so let's make that concrete
let's look at some examples so a strong
Arrhenius acid and actually this would
be a strong acid by other definitions as
well would be hydrochloric acid
hydrochloric acid you put it in an
aqueous solution so that's the hydrogen
you have the chlorine you put it in an
aqueous solution you put it in an
aqueous solution it will readily
disassociate this is a this this
reaction occurs it strongly favors
moving from the left to right you're
going to have the chlorine strip off the
the two electrons in the covalent bond
with the hydrogen leaving the hydrogen
with no electrons so the hydrogen is
just going to be left as a hydrogen
proton and then the chlorine the
chlorine has just
AB that electron it had the electrons
that had before and then it just nabbed
an electron from the hydrogen and so it
now has a negative charge and these are
both in aqueous solution still it's
still they're still both dissolved in
the water and so you see very clearly
here you put this in an aqueous solution
you're going to increase the amount of
hydrogen ions the amount of protons in
the solution and we've talked about this
before you'll often see a reaction
written like this but the hydrogen
protons that are still sit there by
themselves in the water they're going to
they are going to bond with the water
molecules to actually form hydronium so
another way that you will often see this
is like this you have the hydrochloric
acid hydrochloric acid it's in an
aqueous solution just a fancy way of
saying it's dissolved in the water and
then you have the h2o you have the water
molecules h2o and you'll sometimes see
written okay what's in its liquid form
and it's going to yield instead of just
saying that you have a hydrogen ion
right over here you'll say okay you know
that thing that thing that the hydrogen
is actually going to get bonded to a
water molecule and so what you're going
to be left with is actually h3o h3h3 oh
now this thing this was a water molecule
and all it got was a hydrogen ion that
all that is is a proton it didn't come
with any electrons so now this is going
to have a positive charge it's going to
have a positive charge and we can now
say that this is going to be in an
aqueous solution hydronium is going to
be in an aqueous solution and you're
going to have plus now you're going to
still have the chloride ion or some
negative ions we call it an ion chloride
chloride anion and this is still this is
still in an aqueous solution it is
dissolved in water and remember all that
happened here is that the chlorine here
took all of the electrons leaving
hydrogen with none then that hydrogen
proton gets nabbed by a water molecule
and becomes a hydronium so even by this
definition you might say it increases
the concentration of hydrogen
protons you could say it increases the
concentration of hydronium of hydronium
right over here I hydronium ions so that
makes by the Arrhenius definition that
makes hydrochloric acid a strong acid
that makes it a that makes it a strong
that makes it a strong acid now what
would be a strong base by the arena
Stefan ition of acids and bases well one
would be sodium hydroxide so let me
write that down
so if I have sodium hydroxide sodium na
that's the sodium and then I have the
hydroxide that's an oxygen bonded to a
hydrogen so that's sodium hydroxide and
actually if you wanted to see what this
molecule looked like you have a oxygen
having a covalent bond to a hydrogen let
me do these in different colors oxygen
has a covalent bond to a hydrogen to a
hydrogen right over here and it actually
has it actually has three lone pairs it
actually has three lone pairs right over
here it's actually nabbed an electron
from from somebody someplace and so it's
going to have a negative charge it is
going to have a negative charge X I can
write it well let me just write it like
that it has a negative charge and then
you have a sodium you have a sodium ion
that has lost its electron somehow so
you have a sodium ion that has lost an
electron somehow so it has a positive
charge and for all we know it could have
lost the electron to to the oxygen right
over here making the oxygen negative and
making the sodium positive and so this
is now positive this is negative they're
going to be attracted to each other and
they form an ionic bond so sodium
hydroxide they have an ionic bond
because the sodium is actually positive
and the hydroxide part right over here
that is that is negative and that's what
draws them together but anyway you put
this in an aqueous solution you throw
some sodium hydroxide into an aqueous
solution it will disassociate into
into sodium with its positive charge the
sodium ions and actually you know the
sodium ion is still part of this that's
what makes it attracted to the hydroxide
anion but it's still going to be in an
aqueous solution and then you're going
to have the hydroxide you're going to
have the hydroxide anion so essentially
this thing just disassociates this has a
negative charge and it's still going to
be dissolved in the water so aqueous
solution so you throw sodium hydroxide
in water it's going to increase the
concentration it's going to increase the
concentration of hydroxide in the water
it's going to increase the hydroxide
concentration and so by the arena Stefan
ition of acids and bases this would be a
strong or aeneas base this would be a
strong strong base by the arena Stefan
ition now and I encourage you to to look
at that relative to the other
definitions the bronsted-lowry
definition of acids and bases and the
Lewis definition of acids and bases and
see how you would think about
categorizing things